dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly zsolnai-fehér
post estimation is an interesting area
of research where we typically have a
few images or video footage of humans
and we try to automatically extract the
pose this person was taking in short the
input is mostly a 2d image and the
output is typically a skeleton of the
person applications of post estimation
include automatic creation of assets for
computer games and digital media
analyzing and coaching the techniques of
athletes or helping computers understand
what they see for the betterment of
robotics and machine learning techniques
and this is just a taste the list was by
no means exhaustive beyond the obvious
challenge of trying to reconstruct 3d
information from a simple 2d image the
problem is fraught with difficulties as
one has to be able to overcome the
ambiguity of lighting occlusions and
clothing covering the body a tough
problem no question about that an idea
technique would do this automatically
without any user intervention which
sounds like wishful thinking or does it
in this paper a previously proposed
convolutional neural network is used to
predict the position of the individual
joints and curiously it turns out that
we can create a faithful representation
of the 3d human body from that by means
of optimization we have had a previous
episode on mathematical optimization you
know the drill the link is available in
the video description box what is
remarkable here is that not only the
pose but the body type is also inferred
therefore the output of the process is
not just a skeleton but full 3d geometry
it is course geometry so don't expect a
ton of details but its 3d geometry more
than what most other competing
techniques can offer to ease the
computational burden of this problem in
this optimization formulation healthy
constraints are assumed that apply to
the human body such as avoiding
unnatural knee and elbow bends and self
intersections if we use these
constraints the space in which we have
to look for possible solutions shrink
considerably the results show that this
algorithm outperforms several other
state-of-the-art techniques by a
significant margin it is an auspicious
opportunity to preserve and recreate a
lot of historic events in digital form
maybe even use them in computer games
and I'm sure that artists will make
create use of such techniques really
well done the paper is extremely well
written the mathematics and the
optimization formulations are beautiful
it was such a joy to read regarding the
future I am pretty sure we are soon
going to see some pose and skeleton
transfer applications via machine
learning the input would be a real word
video with a person doing something and
we could essentially edit the video and
Bend these characters to our will there
are some exploratory works in this area
already the Disney guys for instance are
doing quite well there will be lots of
fun to be had indeed also make sure to
check out the YouTube channel of Welsh
labs who has a great introductory series
for neural networks which is in my
opinion second to none he also has a new
series called learning to see where he
codes up a machine learning technique
for a computer vision application it is
about counting the number of fingers on
an image really cool right the quality
of these videos is through the roof the
link for both of these series are
available in the description box make
sure to check them out thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time
you